Ever wonder where the expression “sleep
tight and don’t let the bed bugs bite”
comes from?
Well, wonder no more.
Let’s start with the bug of it all: the
bed bug, or its scientific name- Cimex lectularius.
It’s generally accepted that the bed bug
started its feast on humans around 10,000
years ago.
Before this, they are thought to have fed
off of other warm-blooded animals who liked
living in dark, cool places like caves.
But then around 8,000 BC, the bed bugs moved
onto their next meal.
Humans are (mostly) hairless and make an easy
target for a bed bug.
Further, according to a theory proposed at
New Mexico State University’s College of
Agricultural Sciences, the jump likely happened
because many humans around this time were
sleeping on sheets made of dried grass that
were covered in animal skins- an easy hiding
spot for the bugs and one which virtually
guaranteed a regular food source.
Bed bugs have been biting humans ever since.
For instance, archaeologists have found fossilized
bed bugs in human dwellings in Egypt dating
back about 3,550 years ago.
The ancient Greek playwright Aristophanes
wrote about them in two of his plays.
They are spoken of in the Jewish Talmud.
Even Roman philosopher Pliny wrote about bed
bugs in his 77 AD work The Natural History,
saying that their bites could heal snakebites,
ear infections, and other blood ailments (or
perceived to be blood ailments) by sucking
out the bad blood.
Bed bugs are usually associated with places
that are generally kept somewhat less than
clean.
While this isn’t always the case, it certainly
was when people began traveling from one place
to next.
Most relevant to the "sleep tight" saying,
bed bugs thrived in America with the advent
of the railroad.
The motels and inns near the railroads would
be visited by countless travelers, some cleaner
than others.
As Robert Snetsinger, a professor emeritus
of entomology at Penn State University, puts
it, these inns were “distribution centers
for the spread of bed bugs to homes.”
This brings us to the saying itself.
There are a couple of different popular speculative
theories out there concerning this, and one
much more reasonable one.
For starters, one rather interesting theory
relates to how some beds were made during
the 18th and early 19th centuries.
The theory goes that in some cases, beds were
supported by ropes tied in a weave, a predecessor
to the box-spring.
In order for it to support the mattresses,
the ropes needed to be pulled tight.
If they were loose, the mattress would sag,
leaving the bed occupant with an uncomfortable
night’s sleep.
In fact, one reference even refers to how
if a guest had overstayed their welcome, the
hosts would loosen the ropes under the mattress
as a passive-aggressive way of telling the
guests to go on their way.
Another theory is that since people sometimes
slept in long john pajamas back then, it was
always advised to make sure your nightgown
was tied and buttoned tight, to make sure
the bed bugs didn’t get in.
The accuracy of either of these notions aside,
it turns out there is a slightly more mundane
origin for why it's "sleep tight."
Specifically, as noted by the Oxford English
Dictionary, among others, "tight's" adverb
is “tightly,” which, at the time, was
just another word for “soundly.”
So, essentially, “to sleep tight” just
meant “to sleep soundly,” or "to sleep
well."
The first known usage of something like “sleep
tight, don’t let the bedbugs bite” dates
to 1881, though the word “bed” is left
out.
In the book Boscobel: The Novel by Emma M.
Newton, a nurse tells children “Good night,
sleep tight.
And don’t let the buggers bite.”
In this case, “buggers” could mean other
bugs (mosquitoes, spiders, etc.), but the
sentiment is the same.
Next, in the 1884 work Boating Trips on the
New England River by Henry Parker Fellows,
a little girl tells boaters that she hopes
they “may sleep tight, where the bugs don’t
bite.”
This also seems to be a reference to mosquitoes
since they are on a river.
Finally, in 1897 we find the exact phrase
in a usage book called What they Say in New
England: A Book of Signs, Sayings, and Superstitions.
It explains what a boy in New England would
say to a companion as they part for the evening
- “Goodnight, sleep tight, don’t let the
bedbugs bite."
Bonus Fact:
Bed bugs reproduce via the male bed bug literally
stabbing the female in the abdomen with its
hypodermic genitalia, rather than using the
female's reproductive tract.
Once he's stabbed the female, he then releases
his sperm insider her body cavity.
The sperm ultimately travel via the female's
blood to sperm storage structures in her body.
The males also are perfectly happy to do the
same to other males, with their sexual attraction
to one another primarily based on the size
of the bed bug.
So if you're a well fed bed bug, male or female,
expect to have males trying to stab you with
their genitalia.
However, there is a pheromone the male bed
bugs may emit to try to ward off potential
stabbers (and predators), consisting of (E)-2-octenal
and (E)-2-hexenal.